Belfast's the city never at peace with
itself for decades divided the walls and
fences separating the two communities
remain it's like a patient's never quite
sure if they're recovering from a
terminal illness but now they have
something in common the Irish Republican
side of Belfast always hated wrecks it's
the pro-british side though supported it
until Boris Johnson came along with a
plan to partly divide the Northern Irish
economy from the rest of the UK with a
trade border in the sea his former
allies here see that as a betrayal of
the foundation of the United Kingdom
people are very angry about it people
are you do not support what he is
proposing certainly I think he is
underestimated the strength of failing
across unionism in Northern Ireland
where you know we very clearly and
people on the ground very clearly really
cherish being part of this United
Kingdom being a full part of that United
Kingdom but if that's what your friends
think then what about your enemies this
neighbourhood of Belfast has no murals
no symbols of the sectarian divide it is
middle class and successful and doesn't
like brexit in any form it is in places
like this that the unionist hold over
Northern Ireland is most at risk
I think bracelet has clearly transcended
the constitutional question that's not
to say that that conversation isn't
still live and people don't still have
their strong views but yes I think you
are seeing people who are prioritizing
brexit rather than their views on the
Union or Irish unity because it is a
clear and present danger to us politics
of Northern Ireland has never been like
the rest of the UK people don't argue
about whether they're socialist or
conservative left-wing or right-wing but
much more as to whether they see
themselves as Irish or see themselves as
British but what's remarkable is how
political shades of all opinion from the
most staunchly loyalists to the most
social Republican are united against
Boris Johnson's version of brexit and so
opinions are shifting at the University
we spoke to students from the unionist
community brexit has changed the way
that they and many others think and how
they will vote in this election there's
a lot of unionists that I know within my
own community
who have voiced their sin issue if there
was another referendum tomorrow and it
was either to remain in part of the EU
or to leave with Boris Johnson's day we
would look German for Northern Ireland
to progress and stay within the UK as
well and within EU has done so much for
our peace process and a lot of our
funding for Transport has all come from
the European Union to the untrained eye
Belfast looks like anywhere else but it
isn't and both the police and
politicians are warning of the potential
for civil unrest for Northern Ireland
Boris Johnson's mantra of getting brexit
done as trouble written all over it
Laurence Lee al Jazeera Belfast